cooking oil pizza takeaways sources
popcorn mass-produced pastries it's
everywhere cheap easy to make and to
preserve mass-produces and fast food
outlets just love trans fats but this
chemically transformed vegetable oil is
unhealthy and particularly damaging for
our arteries in large quantities it
sticks to artery walls and blocks them
emmy peas have decided to take on this
bad cholesterol in new trans fats of an
individual from providing the services
that way the transfected and recently
she opened up an ungodly who have had a
car corner consuming 2% of trans fats
per day significantly increases the risk
for cardiovascular disease every year
coronary heart disease kills six hundred
and sixty thousand people in the EU
there are big disparities some member
states have already taken action but not
all most of the countries in eastern and
southeastern part of Europe are more
effective especially because they eat
different and they are not so informed
they buy products without knowing what
they are going to it the lack of
standardization is leading to growing
social inequalities in the EU the World
Health Organization estimates that trans
fats should not exceed one percent of
people's total energy intake the
european parliament is giving the
commission two years to legislate to set
a limit for transfer acids in all
foodstuffs